all right so let me start by motivating
ipi shinee with this interactive web
application so in core shiny itself
you know we have the ability to
only render like a few different things
like images and plots and text like some
very basic
sort of core utilities for rendering
python objects let me mention this is
also very experimental at this point and
partially the reason why it's in a
separate package at this point is
we've been experimenting with the
ability to render ipi widgets with shiny
so if you're not already familiar with
ipi widgets
it kind of provides this foundation for
python developers to
like create a python package that wraps
a javascript library
like a a library like leaflet for
creating interactive maps
and provide an interface in python that
people can then use
that python package to
create these interactive
data visualizations inside of jupiter so
traditionally the main sort of platform
for using ipi widgets as jupiter
but we've kind of
provided this kind of
wrapper to
allow you to write the same ipi widgets
code
and just kind of get that into shiny
with with um
in the way that makes the most sense to
so this is kind of a motivating example
where uh i have some data here this is
showing a super zip score
and these super zip scores are really
like
some combination of
percent college educated
uh median income
and
i think population
for each zip code in the u.s
so you can go to this drop down and
instead of like looking at
some combination of income and education
essentially you can look at just
education so you can see
compared to this overall score
uh
percent college educated is a lot more
highly dense than the north east in the
u.s
and then you can see median income is
actually maybe
more highly correlated with this overall
score
it's at least more widespread out
basically three different uh main
measures that we're looking at here
and then this is a density plot of the
overall score
for all of the us essentially
so you can see this overall score
there's a pretty high concentration you
know around zero to twenty
and you know same similar for college
but it's more pronounced um
and pretty similar distribution for
income
and then this is uh
uh the log of the population just if i
didn't take the log here it'd be super
you know
you basically just see a straight line
up here
and then a very long tail
and the point of having these density
plots here is this is programmed in such
a way that i can zoom in on this
application
and these density plots will update
whenever i change the bounding box of
this map i will recompute the density of
these things
conditional on just the zip codes within
this area
so as i zoom in here to like the dc area
you can see like the inbounds density
here there's a
much higher density
of very high overall scores in the dc
area
and that's really a combination of the
college
percent college educated and the income
both being you know much higher in these
areas as well as a higher population i
guess
population density i should say and then
if you want to get more details into
like what specifically is in this view
there's kind of this details tab over
here
that tells me there's 123 zip codes
currently in that bounding box
and amongst those 123 zips
23 percent are considered super zips
which just means their score is like
above a certain threshold and their mean
income is nearly a hundred thousand
the mean population is a little over ten
thousand and the mean college educated
is nearly forty percent so and then if i
wanted like if i had other data about
these um
zip codes
you know i can see other information
here like their relative rank amongst
all of the zip codes and stuff like that
and this is also hooked up to another
map where if i want to click on a
particular county
and see exactly where that county is
i can zoom in on this map
and i can see you know where where this
uh sorry zip code is actually located
and this is currently a bug when i click
on this pop-up the table goes away but
hopefully that will get fixed sometime
soon
where you know i i could click on this
marker as well to see
basically that same information
displayed again so
the repos name is ipi shiny
if you go to the github page it will
have some information on how to install
it
and a quick overview on on how to use it
there's a couple different ways you can
actually render
an ipi widget with ipi
and the first
use
that
it goes over is should feel really
intuitive if you are already an ipi
widget
user instead of like a shiny user
so hopefully most of the audience is in
that
former group where
um you know you want to like always with
any shiny app create your user interface
and in that user interface
use this
output widget which comes from ipi shiny
and
like any other sort of
ui component you want to give it an id
that you'll then reference
on the server
and inside of the server function the
kind of recommended way to do this is to
first initialize
the widget object
when the server first
server function first executes
so this will only run once we'll be
initializing the map just once with a
center
location and a zoom
level and then once you're ready
you want to call register widget with
the
id that should match this id on the user
interface
to basically say i have my widget object
here that i want you to perform like an
initial draw of
um
for the application and then
uh for all of the other updates
you're actually performing side effects
you're not like redrawn or like
recreating the widget from scratch
you're essentially just mutating
properties on that widget
so it's a little bit different if you're
coming from a shiny world where we
essentially
re-initialize and redraw a widget every
time we want to update it
using our code
but here we will
register
essentially side effects so we haven't
seen this yet from shiny but this is
a decorator that comes from the shiny
reactive
sub package
so we saw reactive calc before where
this is a calc you might remember
wants you to return a value so it it
reads some other reactive values and
then returns a reactive value
but with side effects
this also can read
reactive values but you're not going to
be calling this function for a return
value you're going to be calling this
function for
its side effects
so when i say reactive effect
i don't really need to give this a name
because shiny isn't going to like put
this anywhere so i can just use this
underscore and define a function
and then i will read
the zoom
input value which is coming from our
shiny input slider up here at the zoom
and
that is going to then
what this is essentially saying is
whenever the slider changes
update the maps zoom attribute
so map.zoom is like an ipi widget
property
that will be mutating every time the
value of this zoom input value changes
all right so we just went over like the
side effect that
allows me to
change this input slider to change the
zoom level
on the map
but what if i wanted to go the other way
in the sense of
you know i can
also use this control that's directly
attached to the widget instance on the
ipi widget if i wanted to zoom in this
way what if i wanted to essentially have
that bi-directional communication of
changing the zoom on the map update the
slider as well
[Music]
so in order to do something like this
where you're kind of treating the ipi
widget like an input control
to then
update some other
thing on your user interface
then you want to
use this helper function that again
comes from ipi shiny
to
this reactive read essentially allows me
to read this zoom property on the map
object in the same way that i would read
like in a true shiny input value like
this input dot zoom by using this
reactive read here inside of this
reactive side effect
that will ensure whenever the zoom
property changes on this map
this function's going to re-execute and
you know perform side effects
so i'll get the zoom level from the map
here
and use that
to inform this function that's coming
from shiny to update the slider
so this is coming from the ui sub
package to say
update this slider with an id of zoom
and update its value to whatever
the zoom level is on the map right so
this is like you know changes from the
slider to the map and if you want to go
the other way from the map to the slider
you could do something like this
and then this last part here is
basically to get this text um
[Music]
up here showing the current
latitude and longitude on the bounding
box of this map
which will change whenever this zoom
level changes but i can also pan
on the map to get you know a different
bounding box with different latitude and
longitude if i wanted to do something
like this
this is available on the maps bounds
attribute so
normally if you wanted to read this
property in like a jupiter context you
would just type out map dot or map dot
bounds and then
enter on your console and that would
give you the current bounds
but we want to reactively read this
whenever the bounds change
we want this
output to get invalidated and basically
re-re-execute
so that's why we use the reactive read
here
and then from this bounds i'm just
getting the latitude and long longitude
in a
more
usable way
and then returning a string with the
current latitude and longitude uh and
rendering that as text yeah that
basically kind of covers
the core of what you would need to do
something like
you know coordinate other controls with
a widget in terms of like keeping its
state in sync with other things in your
application and also keep in mind that
like if you are coming from like an r
shiny world
and this
doesn't make a whole lot of sense to you
or it's like you know kind of a foreign
programming paradigm that you're not so
keen on using
um
we do also in ipay shiny
provide like a more
render text like interface
you can initialize widgets inside of a
reactive context so there might be
situations where
you really do want
the you know some parameter that goes
into initializing a widget
to come from a reactive value
before we just kind of like had a
hard-coded value of four
but if you just needed like you know
your slider to redraw the map for
instance every time you change the
slider
you could do something like this which
would re-initialize and redraw from
scratch
that that map object which if that
redrawing is relatively cheap
that can be a totally fine way to
approach how to render widgets with
shiny
um and again this is going to feel like
a little bit more natural in some cases
for shiny users
because you're not you're not having to
deal with side effects and we we
generally kind of recommend avoiding
side effects as much as possible because
they can make your application logic
harder to reason about yeah this other
option is available to you
but to really highlight a situation
where you do really want the side
effects
is maybe an example like this where i'm
using
plotly
to render
a scatter plot with say 10 000 or maybe
more points don't worry too much about
like this code this code is just like
fitting
a linear regression to
like 10 000 different random x and y
coordinates
and
then i'm going to create a scatter plot
down here using plotly
but really the key part here is
you know i'm using this register widget
way of
like basically doing all of the work
ahead of time to say here's my scatter
plot i know that this thing isn't going
to need to be redrawn so i'm going to
initialize with the scatter plot
register it to do that initial draw
and then i will
basically register this side effect to
happen whenever i click this show fit
button here
which is tied to this check box
then i just want to basically toggle the
visibility of this
fitted line that
[Music]
i've added here inside of the figure
widget object right so this scatter plot
is actually
two different pieces one the actual
markers like the black dots here for the
scatter plot
but then i've also layered on a fitted
line
um
that thankfully with like the way
plotley is set up you can then mutate
like the visibility of that specific
line uh trace is what what plotley would
call this um so if you tried to do
something like this where instead
imagine
you were creating this figure widget
object inside of a render widget context
every time
you
every time the show fit value changed
you would have to re-initialize and
redraw
you know a ton of different points and
you would get like a bit of lag
because every time
you click it has to redo all of that
work so yeah it's it's kind of a
a line that people will have to walk in
the sense of like this is really
easy and quick to get started with
something displaying um inside of shiny
but if you if you're in a situation
where you really need performant updates
other outputs don't depend on your
widget state
and it's really convenient to initialize
like
this is this is a handy way to go
but
in a case where you need performance
this is this is going to be really
useful so